hello and welcome to this video blitz
game on the ISS see for the sunday and
twentieth of September yeah very very
late upload I am I didn't manage didn't
manage on Saturday usually I have
something more pre-produced but I wanted
to do it saturday evening but simply
couldn't manage so that's a little bit
late but it's the daily three-game
upload yeah we've got a group out here
the opponent surprisingly goes with be
five which doesn't fit at all with the
fianchetto but but let's see what what
happens why it is better but it's not
not like I'm winning immediately or so
97 it's also strange but anyway let's
see going to try to provoke a 4 so that
I can play against the a pond and
against we have an a6 at the moment but
if a 5 is played then night d to be
three as an idea yeah I'm a bit
surprised about blacks opening player
that's really not very good yeah cross
bishops its own going to push the Queen
over to e7 it's now queen queen e to or
not even a five as an interesting move
yeah I think I'm doing this it makes
quite some sense here I see going my
bishop a8 is not helping a lot
interesting
maybe I could have played Queen a form
just picking up before to be to be
honest that would have been quite
interesting but Queenie to is them the
normal move let's say that looks at the
a6 bond yeah maybe I should have thought
about this for a moment if i win the
beep on it's pretty much the end of the
game so maybe Queen a4 would have been
in deep ellum okay going back baby to h2
ok interesting now I actually can take
on d6 if I like not sure that it helps
me a bit mm-hmm I mean it's not bad but
I think I rather keep that on the board
the double porn is not not very pretty
but i'm not sure how we get it really is
yeah so again i can take or i can play a
queen back so that i'm on the sea far
more quickly hmm yeah i think i'm taking
sure it's not not so not so
straightforward now night over there for
night c5 possibly and the simple idea is
just Queen d2 and pick that pawn pick up
the palm
not so easy for him to keep that yeah so
I think this is a simple the simplest
way to do it just take this take before
if I had no I'm not taking on the 60
might have night c44 whatever and he he
remains with a couple of passive pieces
ok so our desperation mode has already
on hmm
so details details
no okay it will never be enough really
but you have to check with cliff if
there's something going on like Opie
should be too I think one issue is that
it's difficult for him now to move the
pawns forward really Queen on a seven is
just terribly placed now and now I can
do yeah I will go here and blocking
blocking things here a 5-4 so let's do
this
c3 queenie queenie to i will get the c-4
porn yeah that was a good practical
decision he was he was completely lost
without the p sacrifice and here at
least he's somewhat active
so let's do this try to block the pawn
and if possible like we nee for Queen a
four-night c2 and then taking Queen a
form
Queen c6 is also an idea
yeah Queen c6 is a threat
no I don't really see anything that you
can do now
can i push the pawn or head I don't
really see a move yeah I was thinking
about that but couldn't believe it check
good night f5 check King g6g form for
King for Queen Jayde made Jack now g4
let's check that as Queen g8 with made I
don't see how he prevented check black
resigns yep so let's go baby was really
I'm a pretty bad opening play or this
the combination of g6 with this kind of
sloth exchange structure is already a
bit questionable but then be five is
some is weakening the position a lot and
here you really have to go knight c6 but
also actually rather well known that you
have to put the knight on c6 in this
exchange structures yeah and here white
is already clearly better Queen B 6 and
this is again helping me for this here
and now now this is a mistake your
Queenie to I just played that far too
that was superficial just Queen a for us
better yeah just directly looking at
added porn how does he keep it probably
he won't all he has to play some very
awkward moves to keep the pawn this is
what the engine is suggesting to keep
this but white is just much better
before I speak a six this week this is a
bad piece
yeah okay the game also is nice but Adam
yeah it wasn't so straightforward 22 or
so again an idea just going there but I
wasn't sure I wanted to check everything
in play first but yeah he can still
really not cover that pawn yeah and this
was a funny idea probably relatively
best to be honest I mean he can just
stay passive but how is he going to
continue if I take him and he is still
sitting on bad pawns and in passive
pieces so the other was the relatively
best idea there should be two that this
make sense stepping out of c-4 yeah I
now be three you need to soften this up
so that your pieces get some something
to do if he takes him something like
this check check me John yeah maybe
maybe you should have tried this I don't
know well it's a neat neat little idea
that the engine is giving every 30 takes
then oops catches is made already
checkmate funny yeah chen qiang Jared
this is made up the funny I could have
done this already yeah I didn't see this
way checkmate cute and so just this
check checkmate is the cut the engine
solution that's pretty nice the queen is
only needing it's dark diagonal
abilities to checkmate at the end yeah
it was basically decided in the
this is just a bad setup yeah Black has
weakened this dark squares and dis left
with passive bishops okay well thanks
for watching